so your ideal woman let's put it out
there okay
I would say she has nice eyes like kind
of caring eyes like eyes oh warm eyes
warm eyes yes because that is true it's
important it's important to the kids too
yes definitely you know you don't want
some cold-eyed freaking Slytherin broad
yeah you know making even serving
muffins to your children no so warm-eyed
um
I would say hard working hard-working
sense of humor is really important yeah
sense of humor or the ability to laugh
even being able to laugh though is also
like having an inverse sense of humor
like if somebody's a good laugher I
think it's just as it's almost better
than a sense of humor because at least
they're they're getting they're having
the joy you know by the way the hard
worker thing I think is really key too
yeah yeah my wife is a very hard worker
and that's that's uh that's great
because then you can do less
no but it is I mean I'm we have a
similar work ethic we enjoy working you
know what I mean and I wouldn't say
working I I'm not saying like hey let's
go grab some construction shifts you
know it's like you know uh it's
fulfilling for us yeah I mean yeah and
life's hard work it's like if you want
to stay in a marriage it seems like it's
a lot of like if you really want
anything to work you gotta do it yeah
um how tall how tall I would say
anywhere probably five
six yeah to six one okay and how tall
are you I'm willing to go on the outlier
side with the height I am six foot you
wouldn't care if she was taller I don't
think I would care as long as she didn't
do little things to me like probably Pat
on Like Pat me or something like that
I'll call you shorty yeah yeah yeah
or say hey give me that little wiener
yeah and things like that and what about
uh
and what about the do you want her to be
younger than you older than you I would
probably say younger than me you know I
want her to be able to Bear you know
bear children if she wants to yeah um
but then I got to make sure that I'm in
a good space too you know I don't want
to be some philanderer right right I
don't want to be a man who's peeking
over the fence and you know talking to
the neighbor's wife right and I don't
want to be you shouldn't be neighborly
you shouldn't be talking even to a
neighbor
um no but you're saying so you you want
to also be mature you want to be to the
point yeah yeah I don't want to be doing
any more like I don't want to be more do
any more conniving or any like I wanna
you know I just want to be locked in
yeah did you have a point where you were
like was it scary for you when you were
like okay I'm gonna get married this is
it like did you have your mom like who
dropped you off to go ask your wife
would you drive over there how did you
do it I was uh my mom dropped me off no
uh no I uh I was
at my brother's house we'd gone back we
used to go back and we'd go to Indiana
and then we'd drive through Chicago and
go to Milwaukee where my wife's from and
I you know my wife and I we had this
agreement that
she was gonna tell me when she was ready
to be proposed you know because you know
the whole you you don't there's no risk
you don't want them to be like oh no and
you don't want you to process no so and
we had talked about we had dated for a
while and
um and I was at my brother's place and
uh we were smoking a cigar in his garage
and I said you know I tell you if I had
a ring I probably would ask her and he
goes oh I can give you a ring I'll give
you a mom's old ring I used it and you
can use it and I was like oh
and so then you're really on the spot
and I was like all right but you know
again I had also kind of made that
decision do you know what I mean so the
decision had already been made yeah you
know I mean it wasn't like uh my brother
told me to do it so I did it you know
what I mean so uh and then we went up
there and I knew that I kind of wanted
to surprise her
and so I did it right in front of her
entire family and she's one of nine kids
and we had done opening presents and her
I had asked her dad for permission he
was like cooking in the kitchen he's
kind of a a great guy but like at that
point we didn't know each other that
well so he was like taking something out
of the oven I was like hey are you I'd
like to ask your daughter marry me and
he's like yeah okay and so then we were
opening presents and all the presents
had been opened and then I I did it and
it was did you feel nervous did you get
down on one knee it's so well I think as
a comedian there's so many
it's you know there's so many awkward
situations we go in you know where you
have a show where you eat you have
a show where you do okay but you can
tell half the audience thinks you're a
I mean so like it was
it was awkward it was uh it was you know
it was nice but it's
I'm also
you know are these these watershed
moments for me
are uh
they're not nearly as important as like
you know
the the moment where I feel like I
really connected with my wife you know
like my child being born there was PR
you know it was special but it's not as
special as like you know the time when
you take a walk with them right for me
yeah there's like a real connection yeah
man or like right those are kind of just
built-in tent pole moments that are yeah
almost I don't want to say old-fashioned
they're very important yeah but they
don't but that it's not like uh it
doesn't mean everything I I for me you
know if I'm that's a good point now I
think it's a really good point for
everybody we put all these old it's
almost like we put these kind of like
tyrannical like emotional attachments to
these moments even though they're they
might not be there because times have
kind of changed so yeah having a wedding
these days which is really just a huge
party that takes so much planning which
is more about the planning than it is
even the vowels yes and this the
unnecessary stress oh God put on yeah
sangria all these yeah you know oh my
God the bread is wrong you know it's
like who cares
I barely know this woman
who cares that's the only reason I'm
here yes anybody mention that
they should have a vote at weddings like
should we do it or not and people have
to really vote that's funny wouldn't be
a bad idea I mean a silent and because
it's also your loved ones so it's a
really harsh thing and you shouldn't be
able to open it until the next day it's
like the vote came in huh well it's and
it's like a Rotten Tomato score like as
long as we get 18 yeah that's it but
you're like yeah 43 yeah that's not good
but what the audience score said
a lot of old tropes and misdirected plot
twists but
a lot of people don't believe in me they
think I'm gonna cause your family should
have a vote should have a vote I felt
because you're bringing that genetics
into your gene pool well you know it
feels like the family overall should
have a vote well there's also something
that happens where
you I think the you know it's probably
different in different cultures and
different family cultures but you kind
of
get absorbed I think I feel like the men
get kind of absorbed into the the
woman's family yes a much more than uh
the woman getting absorbed into them I
mean obviously there's a good point
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one